something that's going awry president
trump said in
speech in chicago if protesters
violate them i'll i'll pay the bill
it's a signal block him up and paddle
hurt their heads it's all right with me
that climate
top-down kind of moral desert hurts all
of america
some since here in wisconsin
brings up on the white church and the
white citizens
it's not to be swept with a clean brush
that should fight more white see the
more white medicines will be here
because this policeman killed who shot
seven times in the back seven times and
seven times in the back
seven in the back there was no threat to
that
the investigation should be and the two
who watched it
they should be indicted as well
because if jacob had shot the police
seven times
he wouldn't get killed he couldn't have
gone home that night come on sir
we need police but not above the law be
fair
be honest yes so in some real sense and
then the young man 70 years old his home
training
says that he has the right to run down
the street with a loaded weapon
now jacob had no weapon he didn't want
to see
shot she runs through with a rifle
killed two people
remember right now saying please give
him a lot of water about bottle of water
we deserve better than this we must
protest until the three of them have
been
indicted right convicted
and prosecuted
they must not sleep at home at night in
comfort
the white neighbors must not be
sanctuary for killers
charlton south carolina st louis
uh locked and lost in the last five
minutes not be sanctuary for killers
we deserve better than this sir america
must be america for all of us yeah thank
you very much for the divorce
paying the taxes we deserve it taking on
the law we're not getting it
so i want to open up tonight i want to
thank you for that
athletes the real sense
these things they fulfill
divine prophecy when they refuse to play
ball and they choose
emancipation over entertainment
david and bible sampson they chose
entertainment over
in a mastermind of entertainment they
fall for people not just for a match
when jack johnson stood up and fought
back
a time when blacks were untouchables to
rise after
the fight that's just the one that's
just so is why when you
ran the race people hitler walked away
he said well i came back home and rolled
rosa and said man either
chris plug athlete
new york so i can't be so
he lost his baseball career every
american has freedom today because of
chris blood
he refused to be a slave same is true
with uh
basketball player um
who uh refused to accept the idea
he couldn't play uh until his time was
up
uh when these athletes stand up we did
we recommend them we stand with them
i want america to be america for all of
its people today
what a great moment to be alive in many
ways
i would say the center of this area be
nonviolent and disciplined